one more quick little item that came up
this week before we break and I need to
play something for you because I know
how you feel about Eli Manning and
Archie Manning the shadow Commissioner
and the Giants are all in with Eli
Manning and he's the guy until he
decides to walk away however long he
wants to play here's Pat Shermer the
coach of the Giants earlier this week
when the question came up as to whether
or not there's an opportunity for Daniel
Jones to be the starting quarterback
come week one here's what Shermer had to
say we're gonna play the very best
player and I and I know we're dancing
around the words there but right now he
lies getting ready to have a great year
and Daniel is getting ready to play and
you know you just see what happens with
it you know but you know we feel good
about where Eli is these are starting
quarterback we've got a young player
that we think is gonna be an outstanding
player getting himself ready to play
does that make you feel any differently
about what may be going on with the New
York Football Giants in what sense I
think you think you've checked they're
gonna play they're good and I you did
checkmate you they're gonna play the
best player which would Bill Belichick
say that about Tom Brady is Andy Reed
gonna say that about Patrick mahomes
hold on are we just like did you just
not listen to the whole clip he said he
liked Manning is our starting
quarterback did he ask for starting to I
don't have a game until September it was
a if it was a true quarterback
competition the head coach would not say
blank is my quarterback in June so like
he's not what you're leaving the door
open he's leaving listen you're so
you're so caught up with your Archie
Manning runs the league take that you
won't look at what's staring me right in
the face
he said the best player is gonna play
what else can he say why would you say
the best player is gonna play the best
players gonna play because he's got to
give the illusion that this is you know
they have to sell this they don't want
to give the illusion of that no no no
they want to say that they're on the KC
model they're on the Green Bay model all
they have to say is we didn't draft
Andruw Jones to play this year Eli
Manning's our guy not the best players
going to play not
Jones is getting ready to play I mean
here's the thing if he like Manning
really is fading that's why they take
Daniel jones 6 overall they believe in
Daniel Jones I've been saying this all
along the evidence is staring you right
in the face when they make daniel Jones
a sixth overall pick in the draft they
believe in him am I taking crazy pills
they said he liked meetings our starting
quarterback that that's all he is for
now but the vet the best but it doesn't
matter for now there's no game until
September the best players gonna play oh
he said he'd like with that I'll bet you
$500 at Eli Manning's starting
quarterback in week one barring any
injury to either guy
I don't bet first of all and second of
all I'm not saying that Jones is gonna
win the job I'm saying the opportunity
is there you would say the opportunity's
not there I do not think of the
opportunities there no I do not think
it's really there unless there's an
injury or Eli Manning is so so bad
I don't think here's on to my baby we'll
see maybe they'll see how bad he is when
they see how good Daniel Jones is answer
answer me this Mike
Daniel Jones and Eli Manning are the
same as that quality let's even say
Daniel Jones is a little bit better you
think two individuals would be the
starter week one because I do not I
don't think it's a you may think it's a
competition I don't think it's a fair
competition
I think if Daniel Jones plays up to what
made him the sixth overall pick in the
draft he will win the competition which
by the way that's another discussion cuz
he did not play up to this six overall
pick in the draft at Duke like let's not
let's not pretend that he was but
lighting it on a ps4 he's been Brian in
it but they saw something in him if he
lives up to that and they're the ones
who were gonna be deciding it if he
lives up to that then I think that he
should be able to win the job because
we've seen Eli Manning over the past few
years all due respect he hasn't been
very good so if Daniel Joan and here's
the other thing do you guys deal with
the locker room big cat if the locker
room knows that Daniel Jones is the
better option they want to win football
games so at some point Pat Shermer loses
his credibility if he skews this thing
in favor of Eli Manning I'm just look
with I don't need to have money on it I
just have satisfaction riding on it
we're gonna be paying close attention to
the quarterback competition or whatever
the hell of this when Giants training
camp opens next month
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports